foreign
what's your prediction for where this
will go I certainly think that it will
continue to grow quite a bit I
that will convince more people that this
sort of Paradigm is really promising for
robotics as well especially in terms of
handling the vast degree of variety in
objects and environments in the world in
terms of looking forward one thing that
I'm really excited about is trying to
train robots on broader data sets a lot
of the field of robot learning is still
collecting a data set for a project in a
lab and then training on that small data
set it's small because it has to be
because you collected it for that
project and so my prediction at least
for the coming years is to move towards
a paradigm where we're chairing data
sets across institutions across robot
platforms and scaling up the data that
these systems are trained on such that
they can generalize more broadly
thank you